i wanted to show you a video made by
some friends of ours uh i think this
kind of shows you what we're up against
check it out
they said you can give me anything
what you're looking for man this ain't a
typical request
look bro i can get whatever you need
guns
drugs women you're gambling man
you like that hard stuff you need
somebody to go away
look you got cash i make things happen
baby parts
what'd you say you heard me unborn human
baby parts sickle
i thought you can get anything what'd it
look like to you
planned parenthood
you know it's a joke but it's it's not
at the same time this is what planned
parenthood does and was caught doing and
yet
half a billion dollars half a billion
dollars
every year from the taxpayer
and it does almost still shock me
almost that these people were caught on
tape
and the tapes are still there you can
see them on youtube selling human body
parts
the body parts of babies on tape
laughing about it
we saw these videos not deceptively
edited by the way that's a myth that's a
lie
planned parenthood did their own
forensic analysis of those tapes
that were done by dave deliden in the
center for medical progress and they
themselves admitted that they were not
substantially edited
in any way that's manipulative or
deceptive they admitted that in their
own report
go look that up too and so this is all
on tape and yet
uh nobody talks about it anymore like it
never happened
and still the half a billion dollars
keeps funneling every year
from your pockets into theirs
with no sign of stopping if it didn't
stop with a democrat congress or
rather a republican congress and a
republican president it's not ever going
to stop
hey you uh yeah you you're right you
right there
hit the subscribe button right now do it
do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it's
somewhat appreciated